hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar cast genotyping better
by design
I'm Judy O'Rourke of Labatt's and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider over 12
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by LGC LGC is a global leader in
the laboratory services measurement
standards reference materials genomics
and proficiency testing marketplaces LG
C's brand is born from precision in what
it provides for its customers and in how
LG seam leads the way in advancement in
many areas of science to learn more
visit WWL GCU comm slash genomics let's
get started
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them if the drop-down box located on the
far left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker Jonathan curry
PhD a senior scientist in scientific
support at LGC dr. curry studied
molecular biology at Birkbeck College
while working at gr micro the company
was acquired by quotient by our research
which is now the LGC groups Fordham
facility he received a PhD in
microbiology from University College
Londyn dr. Curie used a wide variety of
molecular biology techniques and
sequencing during his PhD studies he
joined K bioscience /lg C genomics in
2013 to help build a technical support
team and help customers get optimal
results
one of his first roles was to implement
sequence analysis into magic box LG sees
assay design software for automated
whole genome primer analysis for all
species dr. curry will now begin his
presentation yes thanks very much for
the introduction so welcome to better by
design we're going to talk about simple
tools for effective cast assay design so
what I'm going to go through is a little
bit of who are we and and then how does
Casper work very briefly just so we get
an introduction and then we're gonna
look at how you can apply cast design to
the typical questions so the type of
questions you have can generally be
broken down into four particular type of
design solutions or strategies and then
we're going to look at how the one you
want to supply your sequence to us and
how you go about submitting sequence but
with annotations in order so that you
can give us plenty of information about
how you want your assay designed and in
turn help us and at the very end I'm
going to talk about the importance of a
particular type of magnet take
annotation that you can use and why it's
important and that will then move us on
to part two where I'm going to talk to
you about how you can go about screening
your assays and sequences and use
publicly very publicly available
databases and using blast and simple
tools online and the types of filtering
options and things you can do in apps to
find anchors and what do we mean by
hackers is something we'll also go
through so it's kind of a workflow or
we'll describe each one of those and
then we'll move on to actual worked
example so I'm going to go through what
I did at each stage in order to give you
a nice working assay
and I'll show you before and after and
particular examples of each one before
I'm going to move on to specifically
targeting regions within complex genomes
so we're going to use a couple of
examples we potato and we're going to
look at the effects polyploidy can have
and there are two discrete examples
organisms but you'll the question we're
asking is different of each so I've
given you a few examples so that we can
move on and give you a good overview of
how did you go about dimming listen and
hopefully get some better assays and
simply put better by design so I'm going
to go through quickly who we are we're
one of the largest longest longest
running probably production genotyping
installations in the world and in the
far left-hand corner of the picture you
can kinda see the scale of the
laboratory that we're working in over in
hottest in UK and this is specifically
forecast but we do other things here and
what the view you're seeing there is
from the extractions lab then an assay
manufacturing is in the central image
everything's processing part of a
project all the other guys have received
and we manufacture essays on sign and
then to give you an idea then just how
many data points that we're dealing with
or how how much throughput we deal with
us the far right picture gives you and
the area that we're dealing with
da-rae which is probably about double
that and you can see in all of those
shots different mechanised solutions
that we create in order to get around
bottlenecks in order to speed this
process up so just in the pie chart on
the Left I wanted to give you an idea of
the sort of distribution of life that
passes through the lab in the in between
some 1 lakh 22 2016 and 2017 and you can
see probably predominantly 62 percent of
our things coming through the map of
plant
whereas animal I mean by livestock
and about 80% is human and then the row
manger is made up by vastly different
species and organisms including bacteria
yeast isola insects
of course fish and that could be also
marks as well and I'm going to give you
a quick idea sort of the top two means
the issue shouldn't send the the
companies that we weren't working for
and I've had been lucky enough to work
for on help which is part of my role a
LGC
over the years so let's quickly move on
then - how does cast work so let's start
off with there are with the ways that
you could order assays so first of all
we have something called cast by design
and that's where you submit secrets to
us in effect you said send the secrets
to us and we'll do nothing more but
design it through our in silico problem
design software there isn't any other
any other interaction with us and then
the assay is delivered to you whether or
not it works that's down to you an
optimization you can help of course but
we also offer a secondary service which
is cast on demand and again that goes
through the same a similar pipeline and
essentially prime design but then we
also will then do blast and other
analyses to actually get your ass ain't
working and what we'll also do is we'll
also test this in the lab so if it's not
human if it's human sorry you'll be able
to supplies the asain will have DNA
in-house but for any other species it
doesn't matter which one you can provide
us with DNA and then we can test it for
you so those are the two major pathways
to ordering cast assays from us so
what's in a NASA and how does it work
what the components of what we call a
cast reaction mix
so you can see in the far left-hand
corner there so you have cast a say mix
and that's made of two forward primers
we called me a little specific one and
two one is corresponds to fan and has a
tail sequence that corresponds to the
fan cassette and one has a tail sequence
that corresponds to the hex cassette and
then obviously to complete the PCR
circuit we'll have a reverse primer the
three prime end and this is a very
important part of how Casper works is
specifically tailored to which allele
were going to address so in the example
there we're looking at only one you see
and then allele 2 is going to address
pay and then in the master mix this
contains the floral and quencher
cassettes ie the quencher is band to the
floor for a cassette and both of them
are oligos the quencher is in proximity
and quenches any signal so there is no
background at the start the master mix
contains the ensign dntps magnesium
everything that he needs to support PCR
and then the final part is the template
DNA and this is the part that is
obviously provided by you and that's
essentially the three things that make
up a cast reaction so I briefly
mentioned why is important for three
prime end so if we have a look at how
PCR works essentially this is cast was
nothing more but PCR with an additional
tau sequence now when it's we call a
competitive we have two primers one is
almost identical to the other except for
the three prime end and that's the
important part
so as we denature and then we reduce the
temperature and so annealing the three
prime ends will address whether or not
the the snip that we want to look at
were actually able it to bind so here in
the picture in picture two here we're
looking at see binding to his complement
G now the polymerase within CASP is how
is completely dependent on the first few
bases being completely band and a match
otherwise polymerase was off and there's
no extension again there's a reverse
complement primer to complete the first
round of PCR
but at this point there's no signal
generated then we look at the second one
you've got round three sorry round three
but round two you're essentially
completed your first amplicon and it's
the reverse primer now in the second
round of PCR that's reading through and
creating the anti complement of the tail
now the reason for the anti complement
of the tail is so that when you add the
primers and everything to give them a
new action mix you'll not gain the
quencher and fluor for binding to
primers so it's not until you get the
answer complementary sequence will the
actual cassette bind it with
CASP and stop to generate signal and
this is what we see now in round three
of PCR and it's at this point where the
cassette is now starting to incorporate
into products we've addressed each one
of the alleles specifically and
essentially we're amplifying up and this
continuous you progressively get more
and more signal so for a really really
good in-depth explanation there there
are links in the webinar view that you
can go to have a look at how does caste
work and there are three videos and I
recommend taking a look so you have a
quick look through how casper works and
it'll become more and more evident and
as we go on how the three prime end of
both primers and the way that that
interaction works with the polymerase
and how that codependency in order for
amplification to occur can lead to some
very nice tricks and actually is very
very specific so you'll probably have
questions about what type of variation
that you're looking at
so we can pretty much boil these down to
four particular groups now Annandale is
an in Dell but we've broken them down
into four discrete groups purely because
the small insertions or deletions can
differ slightly just in the way that we
in terminology for us but this is more a
solution to the way that we design the
icing more than then realistically it
being any different to anything to any
other type of insertion or deletion it
is truest sense so the first one we've
seen here is a single nucleotide
polymorphism then it's a or its gene and
then we design one specific primer to
address either so a single base
insertion would be either is there or
isn't always being inserted a single
insertion or deletion would be a single
base has been inserted or a small
insertion up to 25 nucleotides long has
been inserted and that's what we call a
small single insertion rather than
single it's it's a fine line in
distinction I know but actually it's
something that we reference and then
large insertions or deletions now this
could be one base being replaced by up
to 26 or bigger actually and doesn't
matter however big as long as the
breakpoints are known at one end and the
other or there is a sufficient sequence
within the region that we can design a
another type of annika solution which
I'll come on to then it could be any
size so this could be wholesale
rearrangements large whole gene
donations so thinking about how we go
about or what type of insertion we're
looking for or what type of variation
we're looking for can give us our
solution the way we're going to go and
what we go how we go to design so within
a standard cast
a typical I say as we've seen already
with our forward primers are no specific
one and two one will address the a and
the other one here I've got the three
prime end the final base addressing G
and to complete the PCR circuit I have a
reverse primer which essentially works
with both so the next slide gives you an
idea of what typical assay would look
like if you're familiar with genotyping
this this is pretty much a plot so just
for ease and the rest of the remaining
are I've essentially used a little one
is blue allele 2 is going to be red and
then obviously the heterozygous order
essentially one to one of each is green
so here I have a single base insertion
or deletion of course and with this one
here I've said that a little one is
going to address the a but what I have
got is I've got a very similar primer
now and but what I have got is a skip
actually what I'm addressing is the last
two bases at the three prime end and one
is G and one is a and then for a little
- it's going to end in GG now that's a
slight difference and it is just
differing by what a single base but what
I am doing is I'm skipping the insertion
or deletion I'm looking for the next
base that is unique the next unique base
that I can use to differentiate from the
other and again a common primer
completes the circuit and here is this
assay function and you can see the
genotyping displayed there so now
similarly we're going on to insertion
deletion and we're going for for two or
twenty six bases and the distinction
here will become more evident a bit in a
second when I explain some what we call
mega Del's or mega deletions or mega
insertion so again what I've done here
is I'm looking for the next set
of bases that are specific to the target
or the regions I'm looking for and all
I'm doing is addressing where the
breakpoint starts and begins so for our
insertion here on a little one I'm going
to put the 3-prime main base is going to
be 8 and T and then for the allele 2
which is going to be a wild type which
out mean without the insertion and
that's going to end in T and then C so
those are the two bases are
differentiating and that's sufficient to
actually differentiate between the two
you'll notice now that the where the
common partner is the distance
internally is slightly different okay
and that can have an effect as with
anything
as with any idea on how well the
efficiency works and how groups tend to
move so ideally you wouldn't want to go
any further than we have here we've got
probably about 30 bases internally and
that's generally going to be okay though
it would be a case to casein done by
design and as before just a single
common primer can place our PCR circuit
and is that running now I'll just point
out on the group you've got here so when
I ran the assay and I got one one that
didn't actually falling within the group
particularly there so I've colored it
pink and so just as a familiarity and we
will be seeing something like this a bit
later on but actually this becomes a
little bit more useful information about
what's going on what potentially could
be going on so then finally we have our
large insertion or deletion now here is
an overview of what we mean so you can
you notice here that I've got your
little one primer and I've got a little
two primer but I've also got reverse
primer one and reverse two so now I've
made a for primer circuit so essentially
I'm requiring four primers and all I'm
doing again is the same all the other
examples I'm addressing the the bases or
the secrets that I know I
looking for where that break point is ie
where the new site sequences have been
inserted and what is that change from
and all where that change is going to be
from where that sequence is removed so
you can think of it where you slice down
the middle and the sequence for the
primary in the most part for anyone and
a little too roughly identical and then
it's the remaining basis that I'm going
to or you're going to use in order to
differentiate what is the differentiated
between the two so what's the new
sequence versus what's wild-type
what's being deleted so that's why I
mean by break pond I think the next
issue on the next image here it gives
you a better idea of what I'm doing what
I'm saying
now as I remember I mentioned earlier
that we want to keep how efficient is as
fine balance as possible so we want to
keep the PCR as balanced as possible so
that we're not skewing clusters so what
I've done here with a two
well type I'm addressing the front three
prime end is T C T G and then on large
insertion now this could be as on as I
suggest it could be any length of base
we tend to say you know 26 bases and up
but this could be any length of base so
you wouldn't necessarily even need to
know all of the sequence within this
region as long as you knew maybe 20 or
40 bases and within one side that should
be sufficient in order us to place a
common primer and also then know the
breakpoint what is the difference what
are the two different changes so here
from the a1 primer I'm addressing a tea
tea so I'm using four bases as a
differentiator and that creates
instability and the instability is also
very good for specificity so here you
can see that I've run that assay and
again got some pink that haven't
amplified in this instance that might be
indicative of something else going on
but you see 93 clusters as you would
expect and it is exactly the sequence
that I've shown you here is the design
that we're running so let's suppose now
that you've you've had a look at the
sequences and you've got an idea of what
it is
type type of mutation that you're
looking for to design and again so if
you were looking for insertions
intuitions that kind of thing
it could be that you're looking for
Chris permutations you perform some kind
of mutation you've you've seen wholesale
donations something like this and but
you know probably more about the
sequence than we will we will take these
sequences in but there is a way that you
can direct design so from the knowledge
that you have about sequence and what's
doing and what's important it could be
for example that you have a knowledge
varietal information that's important
for placing primers so on this you can
give us that kind of information so how
would you submit a sequence so the first
one or the top example one
it's essentially a and then backslash T
or whatever your mutation is for example
a or two so on and within square
brackets simple you can also just apply
square bracketed and then the iPad code
you can provide us with our s ID numbers
so here we've got one two three four
five six and then we will download that
sequence and run submit for design in
Dells are slightly different where that
if you are looking for an insertion or
deletion that we would expect that
there'd be the sequence that you're
looking at is well type and then you
would backslash and then T's either the
inserted base or is the deleted base it
could be any number of sequence or a
length of sequence
for example if you were looking for a
whole gene had been deleted it would be
sensible probably to provide us 100 BP 5
Prime 3 Prime in Frank with n in the
center and then flanked those end with
another 100 BP which then is pinning
shimoff 3 Prime 2 then into the
wild-type sequence again so then we'll
understand what it is you mean and then
design accordingly so there are some
ways that you can mark special
requirements and effectively what this
does is it's telling our automated
software what it is your you want to do
and certain things have a particular
meaning so for avoiding bases completely
you can place N and ends will we will
avoid completely but what you're also
doing you have to be quite aware of here
that for the example I've got here where
I've placed an N next door to my snip it
will completely avoid that direction so
we will only design the common in the
reverse direction sorry the little
specific in the reverse direction with a
common primer in running forwards so
you've dictated in which direction that
the primer should be designed so there's
two things there you can say I believe
or I'm unsure of the sequence just
flanking five-prime here or I want to
avoid a little primers going in this
direction so moving on then slightly
less or slightly less if you like
stringent is suspicious bases so you can
inform us of sequence that you're not
completely sure about it's slightly
ambiguous you know maybe you have
sequence of results and it wasn't
completely clear again what we'll do it
will shift design in one direction as
first example is so but if that is
impossible
then what it will do is it will use that
as a last resort and then obviously if
you included those kind of things we
will contact you to say are you sure we
can try this then obviously you've got
the situation where there are
surrounding snips and that happens a lot
so from different varieties or mutate
different mutations in human have
different minor allele frequencies so
within a population you might find that
actually it's pertinent to say these are
quite often in linkage with what I'm
looking at and then you can put the
ambiguity code in so what we will do is
design we can design primers freely over
a property back to for the reverse
primarily all specific primers and
incorporate that into them and
essentially that that's okay
more than two becomes quite tricky
because that's the amount of species
organized of primers duplicates that
you're making so synthesis becomes a
little bit trickier for those also if
you're going to say have tri nucleotides
and we will completely avoid it we'll
treat that as as men so it will
completely avoid that region altogether
and then one final marker is the two
Chevron's bracketing a base and this is
what we say is what is an anchor so what
is an anchor is effectively a region of
sequence or it could be a single bases
I've indicated here with two two
Chevron's surrounding the base T there
and that's the single base that's unique
and is unique to the sequence the target
sequence that you're looking at and it's
quite important because as we've
mentioned before the three prime end and
and Wayne the polarizing interacts with
the three prime end our primacy of
specific primers is what's driving
specificity to draw it to detect the
snips that you want to look at so
conversely you would say the three prime
end of the common primer can be selected
in the same way
and this is true and we're going to
dedicate the rest of this talk to
showing you why that is how that works
and then lots of examples of how that
actually it being performed and it's one
of the things that you could do quite
easily if you follow this essentially
this pathway that I'm running for you
now that you could do this kind of
analysis anyway and with freely
available tools so those are come with
special requirements for how you can
give us information to help you design
that stays that work okay so let's now
try to discover what or how we can go
about finding anchors and what are the
type of things that we need to do so we
need when we're checking our sequences
and we need to last and we need to you
actually screen against the databases to
which we are actually addressing so if
we're going to use blast we're not going
to use the non-redundant that dexter
says we're going to use the genome
specifically you intend to analyze and
what we're going to do is we're going to
check for regions of identity so could
it be anchored or more faintly could it
be avoided and again using the same
symbol that were just shown you actually
we can bracket whole regions of sequence
rather than just in trying to find
individual regions that are one single
base for example so we can avoid having
to discriminate against lots of
different sequences that might cause off
a target
that's probably preferentially and then
we're going to compare with other
datasets if it's possible so there are
multiple genomes that we could reference
or could we can take a look at so we can
see whether or not the unique bases are
consistent are they consistent between
different varieties for example are they
the variation between the gene or are
they variant dependent so variant
dependent can be useful at some point
actually if we want to target specific
genes regardless in the Verret varietal
then what we need to do is we need to
make sure that it's consistent and then
we want to compare that variant with the
anointment so have you spotted something
strange and when you look down the
alignment do you notice that actually
what I see is in different regions the
component of the snip for example if I
was looking at G and I was looking at T
and I see very very similar sequences
throughout the genome that also have
that specific position G and T and then
am I going to get a contribution to from
those different places different places
to a genotype so is it a real snip I
think is probably what I'm saying
so this is a good stage actually to take
a look and and ask some questions so the
other thing is that not all species will
have the luxury of multiple databases or
even a single complete Gina some might
be GPS all there might be things like
est tag libraries trans transcriptomic
libraries and he might be necessary to
discover what works and in particular
you have to remember that where the exon
bridges are so for est tags and
transcriptomics little breeze you're
gonna be looking at transcriptome so you
have to remember or I'll have to figure
out where those bridges are because
we're going to be now working in jannat
edge in genome from genomic DNA and so
those things will actually matter for
example is your snip right on the bridge
then for example your reverse primer is
200 more bases away from where you're
actually intending to target and then
that won't work so you don't need many
tools to actually do this and blast will
be the most exclusively used for the
part for the rest of this talk but
they're probably cluster only something
else that you probably might want to use
as well and that'll allow you to align
in sequences that you have so if you
have
have the ability to have seeing sanger
sequences or there are multiple
submitted sequences within a database
you can use cluster very easily to
create a nice lineup and then mark and
use the annotation guide that I've given
you earlier to say okay within within
these sets of sequences actually only a
few of these are actually real
differences actually these are
differences between sequences or people
that amis could well be surrounding snip
so we'll mark those as either aren't
sure or
this actually is a surrounding snip so
you can mark with N or you can mark with
a cube you a tease or if there are
sequence regions from that that you have
that you're unsure of use of another
case so when we could a go and do blast
will be using blast n and will not be
using mega blast other versions of it so
we'll use blast end mega blast
effectively looks very similar sequences
but what we want to do is we want to
look for very very almost to the point
to similar sequences we want to look for
anything that might produce a hit that
might sequester piranhas away from our
reaction and ultimately cause for a
satyr phone we try not to use masks
because essentially this hides
problematic sequences repetitive regions
are a good example and essentially we
can quickly create and search alignments
just to check where our primers are
likely to hit and where we might be able
to then avoid but also AM i-are
necessarily trying to drive as I
mentioned before with I could avoid
actually using a single base could is
there a clear sequence away so am i able
to complete an applicant circuit with a
set of primers could I actually move a
little bit further right place my common
primer where now I don't have to like
so when we look for highly conserved
sequences these can potentially give the
wrong or very misleading results and
I've got an example for you so when we
land on the last page we were presented
with some options and so we're going to
use nucleotide blast but what we're
going to do is we're actually going to
select the genome that we're going to
we're analyzing an organism that we're
interested in okay and in the database
search we can type in if you have the
taxon ID you know that the common name
or the scientific name you can place
that in there and search okay warning
that not everything is here or not
everything is up to date so if you're
working on things other than sort of
model organisms for example hops very
good hop base has very up-to-date
sequences same sole cap for tomato
tomato databases as well what we're
going to do then was we'll paste our
sequence into the paste window so we've
clicked on and we have searched and
we've got a database window to come up
the last search window which will post
our sequence in but we remove the square
brackets and if we've chosen to use base
with a forward slash and base we'll
replace that with an ambiguity so that
we know where we're looking for when we
do the alignment we know where our
snipping it makes actually finding or
finding where arseny appears in relation
to the rest of the sequence much easier
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to click on the algorithm
parameters tab at the bottom and we're
going to make some adjustments so as I
mentioned to you before we which we want
to screen for everything and we want to
make sure that we can see as much of the
sequence as we can and normally I'll
reduce this down to the maximum return
hits or about 50 if you've got more than
that then you've got other issues
but so 50 return sequences is best and
we don't want to tie up ncbi's time too
much and then I'm going to switch off
the filter both of those and I'm going
to switch off the masks and then I'm
going to leave everything else the same
that's the only adjustments
realistically will work 99% of the time
if you just want to do a quick screen
obviously you know more complex
situations might require will require
more complex situations but this is a
very good quick and easy sarena tool to
allow you to do some analysis and guide
prime design so once we've done our
alignment we run it through NCBI and
we've got a return result we're going to
reform so we can view the query in what
we call an anchored alignment and this
just makes looking across the sequence
very quickly much much easier so
remember all we're going to do is we
leave the HTML part alone and then the
second line down the second optional tab
we're going to change to query anchor
for alignment okay
and then what I tend to do is where the
base length essentially well how many
your bases will it run before it will
like a wrapper before a wrap to the next
line I increase that to 150
it just makes viewing it very quickly
much easier so here we have an alignment
view so you probably be quite familiar
with this but this is that where we've
adjusted the actual view on the output
through NCBI so you can see that where
we've I've marked Y and we've got T and
we've got C underneath our wine our
alignment and then we can see the top
here is the sequence and target are
interested in and then we can see what
other sequences are around and
potentially mine interfere with our
assay
so this way what I've done is I've
decided well I'm going to design the
allele-specific primary in the forward
direction because what I can see is
actually if I place my primers a bit
further out and I bracket in this region
I can avoid any of the any new potential
creating a complete amplicon with
sequence and the third row down and this
sequence over here is it's okay
I'm not going to make any complete under
concert so I don't have to find an
anchor to avoid so I've literally marked
with the Chevron's around region of
sequence that I consider is clear and
we'll design in that direction so now
we've had a quick look just to just how
I go about doing it what the things that
you can do to run it what you're looking
for
let's actually look at some worked
examples so earlier on I mentioned where
see snips where I'm not not snips where
they can make a contribution to the
genotyping you're seeing and actually
give you misleading results so hkr2 is
the Gina are interested hcar three is
the pseudogene and they have two
different snips so on hcar - I'm
interested in five nine zero four four
seven and that has a minor allele
frequency of about 0.01 whereas the
higher frequencies known for page car
three RS five seven one eight seven four
six has a math or about forty percent
and they're about ninety five percent
identical so what I've done is you can
probably faintly see here is I've
highlighted two differences and so what
I've done is I've designed the four
little specific primers to run in the
reverse and I'm going to switch between
two different parts of the genome using
just a single base so for H car two
example I'm going to use just three
prime ends
as primer and I'm going to address G and
for hjr-3
I'm going to address the three prime end
with T now that is essentially the only
difference between the two assets and
what we're gonna have a look at now is
what difference does that make
so if I don't hanker it if I just place
this common primer anywhere but I don't
address the three prime end to a
specific base I get a gene typing I say
that looks like it could be okay and
what I'm noticing is that the little two
group is pulling in quite significantly
away from the y-axis and into this of
the central region the heterozygote
group now that may or may not be right
but let's have a look at the central
example and actually when I anchor just
a tea
I noticed frequencies have changed but
what you also get is that now that the
groups are now falling to their the
correct points and the axes the red
group is against the Y and the blue
against the X so what happens then if I
if I address the G which is specific to
the one that we're after rs5 nine zero
four four seven well what you can see is
that actually the frequency is
completely different that I am actually
targeting one specific region over the
other so I can switch between two
different points on the genome by using
a single base okay so let's look at
another example
here is an example or s130 six eight
five zero one now you may look at the
sequence and go well why why have you
gone this way rent but not the other but
actually placing the allele specific
primer in the reverse region actually
addresses quite a lot of low complexity
sequence and that version didn't work at
the assay design so that leaves us no
real choice then to place a common
primary in there without lots of hair
pins and other things so we have to move
out to the more complex sequence but
that brings about its own problem that's
brought about
similar sequences across the genome but
again what I've done for you here is
identified a single base and in this
time I'm going to use G and I've
highlighted around the Chevron's and it
differentiates G from all the others
here is a RA and so here is the essay
before unanchored so you can see that
I'm getting a contribution of multiple
different regions it's not working for
terribly well and I'm just getting a
kind of a group of nonspecific
application in the center now here it is
anchored now remember that I I mentioned
that this is PCR so a lot of the things
that you can do optimization temperature
as well as additives can be used to
improve casts so in the central one I've
used our standard conditions 61 55 and
that's a touchdown PCR and this is
anchored it looks like it wants to do
something else or it wants to be doing
something but it is not it's not great
but noticing that we're attaching it
were essentially anchoring to G and
quite the primer itself is quite high G
C and the annealing temperature is
slightly higher so actually increasing
the temperature 68-62
solves this initially but not
brilliantly but then I've added
additional 5% DMSO and then you can see
that this the result the far right so
much cleaner genotyping and an assay
that scores and corroborates well with
expected frequency we tended to see from
NCBI so now we've had an idea of you
know very simple typical genomes quite
simple examples how we go about choosing
using an anchor and that actually we can
selectively choose between different
regions within a genome we can actually
employ this now into more complex
genomes so one of the very good example
here and this is probably a simpler
example
we like to detect a snip on TBS of the
week Gina and again I've highlighted for
you that I'm going to select the base a
in this example and I've got two choices
either three prime or 5.2 this after one
point note here that essentially we is
inbred it's hexaploid there are 21
chromosomes but essentially it's three
organisms in one and essentially they
are labeled a B and D and they make a
different contribution and oftentimes is
it's required or two no we what what
what allele or what Park genome
structure is actually contributing to a
phenotype for example so we can use the
same methodology we'll screen again and
we want to come away now we want to
target to be s only there's a duplicate
copy that's very similar to one PS and
and to D s and you can see there are
four four alignments there and again
here is the example on the left the
anchored unknown kit and then the
anchored example we've chosen a base a
and we have exact it as well this is
standard conditions there was no other
optimization other than just select
which is the unique base and then design
and run so that's quite a quite a simple
example very similar to what we've kind
of just looked at with the diploid and
here is a more complex example again
we've got more options in this instance
and what we can do we can see yet again
the unanchored x' example doesn't give
us very good genotype and we can see
that there promptly should be three
groups here but again with the exam
anchored example we get nice three
clusters so our final example is where
we're going to you look at potatoes very
briefly
and again they are polyploid but they
are tetraploid and they differ from
wheat in that we're not often trying to
screen through different genomes or
that's that's perfectly perfectly
possible to do if we know what the
anchor is that specific to the genome
contribution but we again we were
employing the things that we've learned
earlier on where different parts of the
genome or different snips can have a
contribution or an effect on the data
that we see and in this instance with
potatoes they they will have their own
ploidy so what you'll find is that
you'll have a contribution in terms of
how much or how many copies so not just
two genotypes and a heterozygous example
but now you can have two homozygous
groups a heterozygous grouped and
because we are now working in tetraploid
we have the option of a middling group
between both homozygous and heterozygous
and in one and a middling group between
a little too and the heterozygous group
so the potential of five different
groups so interestingly can you actually
design CASP assays to that so again
we're going to identify the anchors and
for example four just to give you an
example what I'm going to do is I'm
going to show you how anchored and and
I've selected the anchors that will
target the particular region that we're
interested in and that's the one we want
to measure and a little dosage how much
is contributing so is it one T or is it
40s and an A for example in this example
and then what I've done is also then the
most similar sequence I'm going to show
what the contribution of that might be
so the effects of not anchoring the
effects of anchoring away which is the
Chevron's using I've colored blue and
then I'm going to select the
the a which will target or specific Gina
and then what are the effects happen
there so you can see with the air on
hand good example you can see that
actually you're getting a kind of a
spread of groups but then you're getting
quite a large pole towards our hedges I
why Anil or hex group and you can see
that we're not able to school very well
but it wants to kind of separate into
multiple groups it looks like it should
perhaps so then there are a middle
example of anchor2 g's and i've anchored
away onto chromosome six and that
sequence we saw just now that's very
similar but you can see that this has
done contribution but again i'm getting
some that aren't actually amplifying and
in this instance it was effectively it's
detecting a snip within snip so at that
point on chromosome stay see the minor
allele frequency is for an unknown snip
there is another snip there that isn't
being detected and that's why they're
not amplifying and then finally when we
correctly anchor for our target region
on chromosome 2 we can see quite simply
there are five groups and at each one of
the different samples has a different
contribution of each one their lives and
as I explained you can see that there's
the eighth genotype a baijiu type or
heterozygous genotype a BBB genotype and
I'd bbb-be genotype so again there it's
very very easy to do it doesn't work
with all assays but that's probably
because for the 200 or so that we've
tested and some of the varietal
differences will have an effect on how
primers work how farmers place so the
more you know about
a population group and how you can then
annotate and give us information about
it it will drive how we can design or
what tricks we can employ in order to
actually get this working but this
worked very nicely and author 250
probably about half of them work
straightaway
so perhaps seduced summarize using a
very simple set of guides and as I
explained to you will help each other
transform your data thinking about how
sequence has changed
what type of variations are you looking
at will help you select the most
appropriate design method or design
strategy using the annotation system
then as you've identified what you'd
like to design or how that systems going
to do going to work and will allow you
to annotate and tell us more information
about what it is that you want to do and
we can then design straightaway CASP
assays and that hopefully just our brief
touching on the Casman how it works and
it's a PCR technique so things and the
examples showing is well where are
volatile thermal cycling or I've had it
additives and can help you optimize and
improve assays to but one of the most
fundamental important part of
understanding any of this part of the
system is a screening sequences
proprietor submission then you
understand what the sequence is doing
and using just simple blast alignments
is often enough although you know when
you're selecting bases use more than one
if you're unsure you can identify
multiple different ones and then we'll
try and screen between them and so
identified as much as you can but
obviously if you could avoid having to
anchor and find regions of sequence that
are unique to your target that's always
best and if you have for example this
workflow is probably alright for maybe a
hundred or so sequences but if you have
more and/or you don't feel comfortable
or you would like someone to work
validate it then you can always use our
cusp on-demand service and this allows
you to do large numbers of assays and
then they are also validated in our
laboratory and again any organism can be
sent to us as long as you have DNA
it works on anything so thanks very much
for attending I hope it's been
informative and if you have any
questions thank you dr. Currie for your
presentation a quick reminder to submit
questions simply type them into the drop
down box located on the far left of your
presentation window we will ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. crane will answer as many questions
as time permits the first question is do
you offer this type of service for all
CASP assays yes as I mentioned earlier
in the slices about 402 organisms that
we encountered over about 16 years and
we have in-house human DNA that we can
run your assays on but if you have very
variants which are quite rare
you can supplies controls or for any
other organism you can supplies DNA and
then we'll design and work with you to
hand in hand to get those to get those
going and it's important to know we'll
also supply you the data as we're
working through different iterations of
designs and we're running in the lab so
you get a good feeling of what's going
on and we'll work together a project
thank you do you operate design service
for any organism yes
any organism you mentioned detection of
multiple groups towards the end and
referenced a potatoe example was this
the only example and does this work for
all organisms
I personally tested myself and we know
that it does work in others did it work
for all assays no streamed 200 250 and
probably about 3/4 of those worked and
that's probably because we don't really
understand what the variation between
each one of those different germ plasm
that we tested is so it could be some
cases the primers here a surrounding
variant and wouldn't work we didn't know
enough about them to get them working
and but yes in a large contribution
those things they didn't work and
there's one other example I know that's
published by Janet Fulton which looks at
HL b HL HL B in chickens and she's lived
a copy number variation and how she's
detected that with cast which is quite a
nice and interesting publication so
there's about the only ones that I know
so far but it quite possible that it
probably would work with others as well
I guess I would like to once again thank
dr. Kearney for his presentation do you
have any final comments no hopefully if
you have any problems or any questions
please feel free to send them over to us
and we'll do our best to help you thank
you well thank you for that and I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today will be addressed by the
speaker afterward we would like to thank
our sponsor LGC for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through October 2018
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye